right Lucien good afternoon members
thank you very much coming along can I
take him the emergency evacuation
announcement as ice raid thank you very
much and but can I just ask yourself
your mobile phones just be thought we
start this meeting I have confirmed with
Sonia that we will not be contravening
her in any way to discuss these items
and they are purely on the basis that
they are supporting evidence of
situations so it's business as usual so
we have checked all that information out
okay moving on - what apologies for
absence yeah we have apologies in
councillors Mason and councillor Stanley
fine non-members attending
councillor Ward minutes of the meeting
held on the 31st of January 2019 and
Ikes take those as correct and accepted
thank you thank you any declarations of
interest okay
but I think with user to our usual
process we have pass over there down
there to give us a price C of each
particular agenda item as we go through
it and question anything that you raise
down so this item concerns the Essex
coast Rams this is a strategy that has
been put together by officers
so along with officers from tenebra and
local authorities across Essex and with
professional advice from natural England
and the purpose of the strategy is to
ensure that housing growth in in Essex
does not cause a new impact on protected
environmental sites along the Essex
coast and particularly the impacts from
recreational disturbance which may be
walkers dog walkers and similar
activities that occur along the Essex
coast which is protected in legislation
for its sensitive habitats including for
birds and wildlife so the council has
obligations under the habitat
regulations to make sure that plans and
projects do not have an impact on the
integrity of those sites it's been
identified for the Essex coast around
that mitigation is needed to offset the
impacts from future housing growth
across Essex which is obviously likely
to be substantial when taken into into
account across the whole of the county
and through surveying and costing and
mitigation it's been concluded that for
every new house built a tariff
contribution of 122 pounds Bertie should
be collected from the developer or the
applicant in order to fund this
mitigation so this round strategy
essentially sets out all of the evidence
to support that that Taric the the legal
need through see Katara and the the
specific evidence supporting the value
of the tariff and where the tariffs will
apply and for information
the hold of rupture district was covered
by by that tariff so just to say the the
alternatives to taking this strategic
approach would have been to require
potentially every applicant or they on a
new housing development even one that
only consisted of one new dwelling to
undertake their own extensive surveying
which would have been much more costly
and time intensive than the approach
that has been taken and therefore this
approach is considered to be not only
sound and also logical and prudent and
cost effective in front-loading that
exercise and just to close it's worth
noting that a forum or supplementary
planning document is likely to follow
which will provide a bit more detail on
exactly how the tariff will be collected
and what what types of development fall
within its scope and in accordance
regulations that supplementary plan
document will need to be subjects public
consultation and it would be for the
council to decide whether to adopt it at
a later date so the recommendation
before members is that they know this
strategy that has been produced by the
council along with other councils as
evidence and so uploading to the
councillors website
Thanks then any questions anybody
probably a city question really I'm
going to ask anyway regarding home
fridge because I'm obviously hold which
is right on the end of the history or
whatever you want to call it what
happens about the sites that I have
mobile homes put on different sites I
mean do we look at anything like that at
all because I maybe we've got a site
down there I think that they're
revamping completely and having a holic
whole load of new new mobile homes put
in place I mean they are they're static
they're not okay you can move them but
then you can
don't down the house to build a house
again oh we do either look into anything
we're like that from the landowners
again well any any kind of development
that consists of new residential units
which would include caravans provided
that they are
I guess permanent accommodation instead
of I guess holiday caravans where you
know they might only be occupied for a
certain amount of the year planning
applications that come in for for
permanent caravans would be liable to
pay the tariffs it might be that
applications have been recently
determined which obviously predate this
strategy and and therefore have been
have not had a tariff collected but this
is what I guess this is very much
natural England's new preferred approach
to mitigation for these sites and
therefore there is I guess a line drawn
and you know from really from now
onwards it should be that these tariff
contributions aren't collected so larger
scale developments in the past will have
been screened for the habitats rigs and
the large five hundred homes site in
Hull bridge was subject to what you call
a habitat Riggs assessment and that
determined that actually provision of
open space on the site and everything
else was sufficient to mitigate because
clearly you perhaps got walkers can use
that large open space instead of going
walking along the coast but from now
onwards it's it's very much a
contribution based process instead of I
suppose looking at individual
applications on their on their own
merits which as I've said is quite an
inefficient way of doing it and actually
even for applicants would would involve
them going for a lot more time and
expense than we've guessed as a council
we've essentially from who did that
process for them and remove some of the
some of the burden so yes permanent
caravans will apply bits I guess it from
now onwards and there's not a lot that
can be done legally for things in the
past okay thank you thank you first of
all thank you very much I think what is
interesting if you go to the five point
eight on the document you will see the
zoning and the zoning is quite messy as
you said it takes in the whole of March
very boost attacks from Southend Council
point a large chunk of Basma done quite
ahead of a chunk of it then moves up
into Malden uncle's field
it covers transferred it's it's a
massive chunk and as far as I can see it
would be literally on any new property
there will be 11 which is contributing
towards for these recreational
disturbance and a mitigation strategy
okay
okay well there's no other questions the
recommendation is the subcommittee
results that the Essex coast
recreational disturbance avoidance a
mitigation staff see in practice rams
twenty eighteen to twenty thirty eight
it's as set out in Appendix A denoted as
evidence and uploaded on the council's
website all in agreement thank you very
much right moving on to agenda item
number six
/ - you're getting down okay so as
members will be aware the council is
going for a process of trying to prepare
a new local plan and part of that
requires obviously the technical
evidence is produced to support the
emerging policies in those plans so this
item is one particular one particular
piece of evidence that has been prepared
which has reviewed the council's local
wildlife sites policies so just a bit of
background local wildlife sites are
pieces of lands which are designated for
their wildlife value typically they are
considered worthy protection at a local
level but they are not as important as
other sites which are protected under
other legislation including starts a
special scientific interest which for
example hot keywords is is one of those
sites so these are sites where
development is likely to be highly
restricted because clearly they are work
for your protection for their wildlife
so the review looks at all the existing
designated sites across the district
which were 39 as well as sites that ever
has previously been designated but had
been undesignated in the last review as
well as a small number of other sites
which were put forward to consider and
its assess them against a consistent
criteria to assess their their wildlife
value and it has been recommended it by
the consultants who prepared is that a
total of 46 sites a worthy of blow off
designation and one existing site
Doggett's Pond is potentially no longer
worthy of designation just one thing I
would know is that this is evidence so
this does not change planning policy but
when the council is drafting its new
local plan it will obviously need to
have taken to account this evidence and
it may well be the future policy on
local wildlife sites seeks to amend
amend the current vegetations to take
into account these additional sites
which may be worthy of worthy of
protection so at the moment it's it's
clearly just evidence but it is intended
that this will inform the ongoing plan
making for the district again the
recommendation is that this is noted as
evidence or published on the council's
website okay if this if this goes
through that you're gonna put these are
protected sites does that mean to say
they will never ever be able to be able
doing them it makes it very unlikely
that development would
be permitted on them at least for the
duration of the plan that they are
within so currently I suppose clearly in
let's say 20 years we might be the
another officer is sat here presenting
another local wildlife search review
which which says that actually you know
maybe a couple of these sites are no
longer were for your protection and in
they might be making a recommendation
that actually those sites are
undesignated and I guess at that point
perhaps the the prospect to develop on
those sites is more likely however what
I would say is that the vast majority of
these sites are likely to be protected
under other designations no least not
least that we've in the green bow and
therefore there are also other reasons
why development on these sites may be
unlikely but this local wildlife sites
designation gives them an additional
level of protection for their wildlife
value if that were like value
deteriorates then there is obviously the
prospect that they may be worthy of on
designating but that's a I suppose a
decision for this council at a later
date depending on the evidence that
exists at that time okay thank you
master Walter you know if you see
because the baggage point it is that
particular one in close proximity to you
rotation in terms of a flutter cutting
education I can check the exact site
down
it is obviously in the vicinity if it's
not too distant from from the allocated
site in Southeast Asia but it's not
located we mean that site and therefore
the designation at that site we've never
likely to have an impact on on that site
being developed and the under the
undesignated it if that's what the
council chooses to do fruits like does
not necessarily make development on it
any more like so than it is now because
clearly it is also subject to other
other constraints which are likely to be
factors so I suppose it's there is a
fine line between sites that are
protected for their wildlife value and
therefore afforded greater protection
for planning policy and sites which are
also designated in the green belt and
other designations which perhaps have I
suppose more numerous reasons why they
might not be developed so the
declassification of a site doesn't
necessarily mean that it's any more
likely to be developed it's purely on
the basis of its wildlife value
and with us in my ward and I don't know
if I need to Ray you say read through
the details lost don't understand wires
been removed from the list I still can't
get my head around them because I do
live around that area and there is a lot
of wildlife around that area birds and
animals wild animals and if you can sort
of explain the reasons behind it that
would be great you know that's ok I'm
just trying to I'll just get some the
specific assessment for that site I mean
I suppose it's worth it's worth pointing
out these recommendations have been on
the basis of surveying done by by
ecological specialists on the basis of a
specific set of criteria so my my belief
is that the reason why they are
recommending that that it is potentially
unlimited is because they consider it no
longer to meet criteria so it might
still hold some wildlife value but
obviously if we were to go to a you know
a local plan examination and be trying
to justify to
government inspector why why we are
proposing to designate certain sites it
would have to be on the basis of I guess
robust evidence about the wildlife
qualities of those of that site and
clearly I mean in this case the the
consultants who have undertaken this
assessment consider that that site no
longer is worthy your protection I mean
it doesn't necessarily mean that the
council has to choose to undesignated
but it might be that it's something that
once the local planners has developed a
little bit more the council wants to pay
more attention to in terms of whether or
not they consider at that point in time
which may be you know more than a year
or two away whether they think it's
still or whether they think it's
justified to to consider undesignated
their site so I suppose what I'd
reiterate is this is evidence but it
doesn't it doesn't constitute policies
for dogging spawn is still a designated
like a wildlife site it's still
protected from from development in that
sense it's just what as the council is
drafting you know it's new local plan it
will need to consider and this obviously
includes members the members making the
decision whether or not all of those
sites is still worthy of designation and
in this sense it's
I suppose that the consultants have
surveyed the site on more than one
occasion and have considered that it
doesn't take enough of the material to
be worthy of designation I mean uh
unfortunately I'm not an ecological
works but so I couldn't necessarily say
exactly why that is but it but it is
know nonetheless their professional
recommendations
yes thank don't think thanks Laura
in detail response on that but I still
feel uncomfortable and imagine on the
table - until we review their policies
the that remains as a designated site
but I I'm only going for a experience
and living in the area and the usage of
the area by residents and outsized
bodies where they they do do a lot of
activities down there now I don't know
how to formulate this motion but I would
like some advice in on my officer in a
how to take it forward
I've just been having this very
conversation George good in and then we
come back to it I think that because I
know that I asked obviously any question
- it's the answer which I knew with
development at a Shinto and its close
proximity I think in quickly contentious
and and I think it should be noted even
though we're noting this this document
this particular item should be noted
concerns its change of designation and
highlight it concerns policy you know
when this comes back it needs to be
discussed further because I wonder if
that was because of it I I mean just
spent the other cows would we can
certainly make a note to this effect
yeah I mean it is pleasing to know that
we've actually included a new size but I
mean the concern has been expressed by
about Doggett's ponds we will highlight
that as as you've requested I mean it
just says well suppose the point I would
clarify is that this document will
change policy so if planning application
came in in a month's time to develop
Doggett's pond I mean if the local
wildlife designation would still be in
place or therefore amongst many probably
many other reasons you know that would
be a reason why that would never be
countenance I suppose the the suppose
this document is evidence so it's it's
it's not going to change policy but it
it could be used to inform a new policy
approach and so I suppose the
recommendation that's being made does
achieve I think what you're asking for
in a sense that it is not going to under
there's not going to be classified this
site but I'm happy that before we
present members with any kind of I
suppose local plan approach based on
this evidence that the issue of WH pond
is revisited to consider whether or not
it is a robust position to to consider D
designating in I mean the report itself
just to clarify says that the there is
limited species of information available
and they've said it's not certain that
the certain selection criteria can be
met so on that basis I'm happy that
potentially on the basis of revisiting
that it's not impossible it's not
unnecessary unlikely tha that those
species are present
it's just that clearly we we've got this
professional information in front of us
that potentially needs needs a double
check essentially but I suppose the
crucial thing is that this this evidence
will not change policy on its own and
therefore there's no there's no nothing
likely to but nothing likely to change
as a result of this evidence I mean our
officer Walter will reflect this these
concerns in the minutes to George and
they say with those dueling noted in the
minutes the recommendation is that the
local wildlife science review of 2018
set out in Appendix A be noted as
evidence and published on the council's
website
take care account of the issues that we
have highlighted okay yes sir I know
cheat on none of these you've got a lot
of the different sites are either
ownership run by somebody or but you
don't know who's owned it where does
that where does that put the kit the
counter in place if you wanted to I know
redeveloping people who own these sites
do they know about what this this
document just and then once the sites
that we don't know who owns them and
maybe later on you want to do something
with it how do you go how'd you go about
so in terms of the landowners of sites
that are in this you probably you'd
likely find a lot of them are public
land whether that's land owned by this
counts or land by owned by six counts
counts or land by owned by other public
bodies there are some sites that are
owned by private landowners but the vast
majority of these are sites which have
been historically designated as Nevada
sites so therefore then this is nothing
new to those people the in terms of
with whether a private landowner would
want to see the you know any of these
sites developed and whether that might
conflict with this local wildlife so
it's designation I mean if you in some
ways the the fact that these sites are
rich in wildlife means that actually
developers cannot well sort of say
landowners cannot take action which
purposefully deteriorates that wildlife
so if a private landowner owned a piece
of land that was designated as local
water so and they subsequently wanted to
field houses on it the likelihood is
that would have to be scrutinized very
very very heavily because there's no
doubt that that would happen if an undue
impact on that wildlife that would
either need to be mitigated or you know
in some way compensated in terms of
whether the council was likely to want
to consider developing any of these
sites so I would say it's unlikely that
the policy function this council would
consider actively recommending science
which it knows that conflicts with these
local wildlife sites you know perhaps
where they are within a wider area or
they are adjacent to you know perhaps
that development would need to deliver
some kind of buffer or mitigation or
compensation it's it's unlikely that
development would ever be permitted on a
block water so unless we could I guess
demonstrable show how that wildlife can
be I suppose recreated elsewhere so and
that's not just we've been planning we
know there there are that does spread
into wider laws about protecting
wildlife
and everything else so hopefully Alice's
okay here fine thanks very much [ __ ]
okay thank you for that
Dana okay moving on
item number seven area very close to my
own heart here go again then yes so so
the council along with officers from
Bath urban crosspoint and South Bend for
our council and supported by
representatives of sporting have have
jointly commissioned consultancy to
basically undertake a an assessment of
playing pitch and build facilities
within districts and within the
neighboring authorities listed so this
included I suppose both quantitative
assessment in terms of considering
whether the amount of provision was
enough and was going to be enough in the
future particular in the context of the
like fees population group of the area
but also looking qualitatively at
whether the those facilities were of the
right quality to to actually support
back use whether there was need for
maintenance or improvement so this these
strategies and actual plans have been
developed primarily to provide evidence
from the planning perspective in terms
of what actions are likely to be needed
to address languages and milk acidities
in the future particularly the context
like assay of the future population room
but there have also been engagement from
the council's leisure and open spaces
teams particularly with regard to
recommendations on our maintenance and
another issues like this so primarily
the recommendations
tend to be quite positive there are only
a small number of areas where the
district is likely to be I suppose in
severe need of action with regard to
playing [ __ ] and that's particularly
with regard to 3G artificial pitches
which are currently quite what's
uncommon and which are increasingly
preferred over there are speeches
because they can handle obviously much
much more playing without deteriorating
however other other issues with we've
supplied were noted however these are
only quite minor and are likely to be
resolvable relatively easy and in terms
of quality pitches in the districts are
generally of the standard of good
quality and it was noted by the
consultants that this district compares
quite favorably with national national
ii in terms of the quality of its
playing pitches so the other aspect of
this was about indoor build facilities
so that's mostly leisure centres but
also kind of local halls that might
house some of this activity generally
speaking the recommendations and me were
not particularly extensive it was mostly
around exploring opportunities to see
where the school facilities could be
used to provide some additional
additional capacity in areas which do
not have fantastic existing capacity and
a need to work with neighbours to
consider how the future demand for
square swimming can be accommodated what
it doesn't do is suggest that that any
significant additional provision is
needed and as I'm sure you can imagine
that the type of population growth
needed to justify a new leisure center
or something like that
actually quite quite great and and thus
whilst developer contributions may be
sought to improve facilities and improve
capacity they would not suggest thing
that we plan for whole new facilities in
their own in their own right and it is
just worth saying that they particularly
singled out let us all as a sensor as a
facility that they consider to need
investment which obviously extends
beyond just the planning process so it
is this strategy in action plan ease is
just a point in time assessment and
there is an ambition that it will be
regularly updated to make sure that it
stays today and local sports clubs are
kept in the loop about what's likely to
happen in the future and it is also
worth just just noting that South Essex
wide playing pitch adversity strategy
has been prepared which brings together
some of the more strategic cross
boundary issues however that will be put
before members at a later date once it's
ready therefore the strategy has been
being shown to members now are just
those recommendations that relate to to
Rushford so the recommendation again is
that these are noted as evidence
projects website and subject to reviews
these can be used to inform the
counselors approach amazing local one
okay Oh God kick off with some of these
leave you've suggested in there that
these will be regularly updated these
week what Cynthia you talking three
years five years I think should be less
than that I think the ambition is that
there will be there will be a steering
group or an implementation group
established so that will have on it
representatives on the council likely to
include potentially leisure and open
space offices particularly as well
representatives from local clubs
representatives from England and that
will consider I suppose the need to
review the findings of this and make
amendments to the recommendations so you
know clearly it is are moving moving
feast into the terms of you know there
there is likely to be a guest
fluctuations in demand fluctuations in
supply you know clubs the emerging clubs
that you know for one of a better phrase
go go bust and therefore it is all only
ever can be I suppose a point in time
snapshot of the of the the health if you
like of playing pitches and facilities
at that point in time but the ambition
is that it will be regularly updated and
that in my mind means you know really
looking at a new set of recommendations
and action plans potentially every 18
months to 24 months and I suppose from
our planning policy perspective
all england have produced what they call
a calculator in order to help to help
consider what kind of additional
provision might be needed to to support
potentially new developments and that
will take into account the most
up-to-date evidence on pinched capacity
pitch quality so if a development is
adjacent to a lot of unused itches you
know the need for new pitches is going
to be lesser than you know if it if a
development is in the vicinity of
pitches that are in use
you know 9:00 to 5:00 every single day
of the week you know so in so it is it
is I suppose evidence to inform that
policy approach I haven't placed much
emphasis on the recommendations that
have more to do with the operations and
maintenance because clearly that's a
wider question for the council not
particularly within my planning policy
remit but it's worth saying that both
leisure and open space offices have been
engaged in this process and should they
wish you know this is obviously a bank
of evidence for them to I mean I mean it
seems to me from my experience of being
involved in this the present lack of
interest in utilizing the pitties is
just allowing pitches to rest and
recuperate from many years of heavy
heavy use I mean which is now that I'll
have been used for a second maybe third
year he's doing them no harm just to
rest after all the thing I've been and
quite coincidentally I was approached
outside this situation to seek guidance
about how one particular Club might
become involved in obtaining sponsorship
for the 3-2 pitch in the district so
they are voting with mr. Hutton and mr.
Aldridge on this this aspect at the
moment so you know we are actually
moving down the road that he's is being
recommended quite independently yeah I
suppose
the thing with with 3d pinches as well
this is thinking about how I suppose
growth and contributor things so things
like that so you know it it can be
difficult I suppose for for for these
big things to be funded especially if
they're by clubs who you know only have
limited means but you know I suppose one
roll of planning policy when it comes to
playing pictures and everything else is
is considering actually how development
can help help deliver some of these and
webinar points whether that means the
futures protocol district be what it be
what it may
helps to fund new 3d pictures helps to
funds you know the quality improvements
that local issue sensors you know that
that's can only be a positive yeah
definitely
anything else and I just on page 73 it's
the research findings when it says the
witnesses and one of it is it's the poor
quality of greensward Academy is
deteriorating the client urgently in
significant investment Greenville
Academy has been spent a lot of money
over the last year or so couple years or
so updating the whole of their
facilities I don't know whether that's
not been taken into consideration well I
might
whywould says say I suppose is that this
report is now I wouldn't say it's it's
old but it's it's not it's not based on
I suppose assessments that
is very very recently and that I suppose
really highlights what we've discussed
about the need to review because it
might be that actually when they were
when this report was being from actually
greensward subsidies were you know
perhaps not particularly strong compared
to other other facilities in the
district it may well be now but actually
that investment taking place and
therefore those facilities if they were
really serve aid would actually come up
very very strongly so it is
unfortunately I suppose the the main
issue with with evidence based reports
is that you know they are accurate at
the time of writing and then some things
change very little over a long period of
time and then other things like I
suppose taking a snapshot of page
quality and everything else there is
obviously always that risk that elements
have been become out-of-date quickly and
no doubt if we review this you know
began another review now and then came
back to this group in say four or five
months with another thing it might be
that in that interim period you know
there might be other changes that aren't
reflected so it is it is noted and I
suppose all right all I can say is that
as part of any review obviously any
Chinese of circumstance will be picked
up that's more of that it's just I know
that even even things like you know
local for fourth up deciding to to fold
you know that might actually have a big
impact on these figures but if it
happens a week after we've signed up for
the report you know it you see what I
mean it becomes out-of-date quite
quickly so and something like this is
very very unfortunately very very prone
to becoming outdated about I suppose
mostly about numbers and
things like that whereas something like
the local wildlife size review it's
unlikely but if you go to a local
oversight review from one week to the
next they'll all be much changed you
know any deteriorations over a long
period of time so yeah I suppose what I
would say is that any changes will be
picked up in the review and you know I
hope we'll hope to be in a position to
bring back something to this group you
know probably in the next 12 months
and it may well be it may have a
different name but it's likely to be
material okay
I mean when I mean when when this was
being prepared
I think discussions were were held about
about these ledger centers and about
obviously the contract that currently
exists and it was notify kept offices
another part of the council that
actually it's not the case I suppose
that we can suddenly make demands or
suggestions or anything for the way
they've the existing contracts it's
written and therefore some of these
recommendations are obviously a bit more
longer term and and they're a bit more I
suppose about things to bear in mind I
suppose when the council is considering
how to it's how to proceed with that or
any you know existing or future
contractors who may take that on it yeah
I mean it's it's a difficult one that's
opposed from a planning policy
perspective because obviously this is
the kind of issue that Strether was a
lot of different areas of the council
and whilst this has been primarily
developed from a planning policy
perspective it obviously is also I
suppose makes the kind of
recommendations which really would need
to be picked up by other parts of the
council who are responsible for the
leisure centres and they're responsible
for playing pitches and whilst those
people have been engaged but you know
obviously it's all all it does expose is
is is provide information that they can
choose to use or not use but I would
hope that it provides information about
you know I suppose sport and sports
provision within those letter centers
that is all used to the letter
contractor and is abused
so we're making decisions about how to
proceed with that but if if that
contract is unlikely to be in the next
couple of years then then again a review
of this may actually bring out things
are a bit more I suppose
poignant at that point in time so it
isn't something that's been considered
in greatly selling beer because clearly
I suppose to some extent it's not an
Impala C's role to try and try and
necessarily influence the outcomes of
that contractor process but hopefully
like I say it provides information is
still relevant and usable for for those
other teams should they should they want
to do it it may be the day to use to
actually undertake you know at least a
their own you know beer market research
or whatever and make make
recommendations based on based on their
information as well
hopefully
catwalk yes thank you very much
it's just following all from what Kelsey
western clarity because the British
Parliament actually stays beautiful to
actually to know when that commissioning
was so that could have been 2015 the
report was actually completed in
November 2018 and we're now I brought
2019 and so you know looking at a moving
target which has moved on quite
considerably and I guess things have
either got better or they've got worse
and so I think it's worthwhile always
when we come to doing something like
this is just putting a caveat in there
which will save the kind of questions
that actually councillor Western has
really pointed out with regard to
noticing the greensward is not what it
was but it has improved and I think that
would come up you know so much and it
would help to explain to a future
readers that you know save that question
keep on coming up hang on this is
changing this hasn't happened it just
explains really in the front that you
know we've got a moving target here this
is a snapshot taken at the time of
commissioning and it takes this amount
of time to publish it blah blah blah and
you know it's basically a snapshot yeah
I got I think you know all the points
have been raised we will reflect in the
minutes quite quite clearly I think all
of them have been very worthwhile and I
hope that you know
we'll be around next year or so - to see
some of them implemented and the
recommendations that we all thought if
there's no other questions the
recommendation is that the Rochford
District Council playing pitch strategy
and indoor built facility strategy set
out in Appendix A and B respectively be
noted as evidence and published on the
council's website just before I close
the meetings that is the last item this
is obviously going to be the last
meeting potentially where the committee
as was with me
can I just thank you for the support
what we've achieved over the last year I
think we've done quite a lot of work
that's not you know successful as we
might have life in some areas hopefully
if you wish to be involved again next
year you will be thanks Dan for your
contribution has been outstanding
particularly in light of the fact that
where we once had three planning offices
we've now got one oh sorry policy often
and planning officers we've got one and
the knock-on effect that has had as had
on you hopefully by the next meeting
they'll be some support for you thank
you
no you can't